oh I'm so excited to be here there we go
and I definitely can't wait to talk to
you more inside you need to go on
paradise will this happen
yes hell yes I mean I didn't get asked
out but I mean Khan let's be real I
probably was just casted for paradise
that's how I feel but yeah I'm excited
hopefully any guys you can think of
you'd like I didn't want to smash her
before so like I don't really know
anyone so that's why I'm excited for
Rachael so that I could get her leftover
meat so maybe I'll get her leftovers
Chad Johnson said he's been asked to
return I know I kind of think I kind of
think the child is funny
I think the Chad is really funny so I
might be down for the job this is
pretend your Hitler if I'm here friends
with you let's not pretend I'm Hitler
good that was so big she walked out of
the interview okay so you're you a child
into the Chad I'm attracted to the Chad
but I don't know I've never met the Chad
so I can't really say I can make that
out of it
I'm nervous oh yeah what are you scared
of I don't know I don't know no I want
to go and look like I I'm judging him
from TV so I don't want to that's
happened like I'm shark girl so I kind
of want to like your shark person your
shark girl he's meat man what would your
first opening line to him be I don't
know I mean I hopefully Reagan has good
I kinda wanna like meet new guys he's
new to you that is true but I I don't
know I'd rather just nobody knows that
nobody know them besides Rachel and
America actually so this kind of sucks
what do you like about the Chad he's
funny yes I only watch one episode of
Mazarin Paradise so I thought he was
funny so that's pretty much it
head and I like them oh my god oh my god
up there start girl and meet man Chad
will say would you ever be better would
you ever be Bachelorette he'll know when
I would never would I first of all I
forgot everybody's names within five
minutes they would have to have like
name tags on them because I would forget
everybody's names so no I've never did
too much motion or too much dress just
send me the pad to go to paradise I'll
be good with that
[Music]